hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the fie diagram
3 2019 as you know some of the games
went into tiebreaks as two of the class
4 games were drawn such as the case in
the match between Hikaru Nakamura and
Timur a job of their to class for games
and Ross another playing the 25-minute
rapid game also two games and then if
that's drawn then they're going into ten
minute rapid games and so on and so on
until Armageddon is is on the board so
without further ado let's check it out
and we also do have a nice photo of the
venue if you're interested in that I
don't know if you've seen it so this is
the venue where the players are playing
in Moscow there have it a job of rolling
it out with Nakamura and young street of
Duda with with Wesley so as they also
have drawn their classical games and
there you have it a lot of people in the
audience you can see that it's it's
pretty crowded in there so as I said
let's check it out
Nakamura has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 with Knight to f6
c4 e6 90 to f3 and of course we have the
Queens gambit declined it's d5 Knight to
c3 Bishop to e7 with Bishop to g5 and
now h6 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to h4 and now D captures on c4
white place III prepares the recapture
the gambit pawn wood Bishop captures on
c4 and black takes this opportunity to
strike in the center with c5 with Bishop
captures on c4 see capture son d4 now
Knight character son before and here
both players just Castle and here Bishop
to d7 the the standard move in this
position it is the D most often play
move in this position the bishop will go
to the knight will be developed to c6
maybe then if Knight captures this
Bishop will assume this excellent
diagonal and here there are a few games
in the database where Queen to b3 was
played and there are a few moves where
Queen to e 2 was played most notable
game with Queen to b3 is Lokhandwala
versus which one a time-honoured in the
last year's Bundesliga which ended in a
draw but Hiro Nakamura goes for a queen
to e2
he has a different plan we have Knight
the c6 going hoping for this exchange
rook F to d1 nicely
developing the rook on the same file
that that the Queen occupies soap Queen
to b6 we have Knight back to f3 not
allowing this exchange on d4 and now
comes Knight rook F to D a black also
wants to counter White's rook on the D
file the Queen nicely defends the B to
point if you were wondering about that
we have E for by white and this is the
only move that has been played in this
position since this is not a new
position we have Bishop - I ate offering
a trade of rooks and now comes C 5 and
here this position has been reached
before twice actually in the 2003 two
games were played in 2003 in the Chicago
pinned between Alexander hobble off and
the Gregory katana were Knights to h7
was played and a white was able to win
both of these games but here we have
Knight to d7 better job of and it is a
new move so it is now as of move 15 that
we have a completely new game on our
hands
so with Bishop captures on e7 Knight
captures on e7 and now nakamura takes
this opportunity to gain control of the
d file with this very nice rook lift
rook to d6 rook a to d1 is being
prepared and the black has to react SS
queen is under attack
so Queen to a5 you want to keep an eye
on this diagonal as of course when a
Nakamura plays rook a to D 1 which he
does now you will be able to at some
point move the knight and your rook will
be nicely protected Knight to f5 our job
of pushes Nakamura's rogue back with
Knight 6 to d2 and now Knight the f8
just offering a rope trade and if white
were to go for this you don't really
gain anything just captures captures and
you've really just solved the blacks
problems of what what to do with the
rooks especially with what to do with
rook on a8 so here Nakamura plays Bishop
to d3 he says we're just gonna keep the
tension here and now if you go rook hate
to see it it is a possibility to develop
the rook this way but then white has a
very clear you know a course of action
Bishop captures an f5 and now after the
rooks are traded rook captures
Knight captures he captures on f5 now
you get Knight to c4
it comes with an attack on the Queen and
you also get this very nice d6 square so
you don't wanna know how this after
something like Queen to a6 you are
coming to d6
and then after let's see Queens are
traded off you can go Luke the eighth
but then just f4 you can even solidify
in the center and white will just have a
very very comfortable game so a job of
instead of developing the rook this way
first he goes
Bishop to c6 just grabbing hold of this
very nice diagonal but now Nakamura goes
to Bishop to e4 now he does offer a
trade of rooks we have looked at for
somebody to roost after sandy - and now
if you go Ruth to d8 then Nakamura has
this possibility of just trading bunch
of characters from characters and then
playing against Blacks - isolated points
on the queenside
reserve isn't interested in this he goes
look to c8 just defending the bishop now
the group will be able to recapture if
Bishop captures the bishop has played
with H for preparing h5 and also
stopping g5 from black with a6 preparing
b5 on the Queen side and now h5 just
grabbing more space and really not
allowing this night to get into the game
maybe with Knight to g6 to f4 with b5
and now a three just a nice move now the
knight can move dat phone will not be a
target but also preventing before
capture Sonny for with Queen captures on
e4 and now comes Queen to b6 just
getting the Queen out of the way and
waiting to see what white will do and
here as you can see the Queen assumes
this very nice diagonal so here there
aren't any tricks at the moment but you
know for example if the rook was on e -
then you could have something like nice
- g3 and of course the pawn is pinned
you would lose lose material here and
even though there's a no such tactic
just yet Nakamura just placed King to H
- you know better be saved and sorry and
now we have Queen to a7 preparing rook
to c7
that's a really grab hold of the of the
seventh ranked Queen to d3 now grabbing
hold of the D file and also freeing the
e4 square for the knight now the plan is
Knights to e4 and nakamura wants to
bring this Knight over to d6 which will
in fact be a monster night or what a
black will be a force to capture it and
then white will just recapture with the
pawn and have this beautiful passport
already on d6 we have looked to c7
better job oh and now comes Knight to e4
as planned he wants to go over
over to d6 we have rook to d7
challenging whites Queen and now of
course nice to d6 and here like we said
you will either leave the knight to be a
monster night on d6 or after captures
white will get a very nice pass pawn on
d6 so first we have Queen to b6 but here
Nakamura just plays g4 forces the knight
to move and now you can either play
Knights the e7 or capture those are your
options really and if you go 97 then
White has a couple of action options you
can just keep the night there play Queen
before maybe trade Queens or he can even
try g5 started an attack on that on the
Kings side say Knight a5 captures
captures and then either decide what you
do try try to play an attacking him or
just play Queen D for trade Queens and
claim that his position is better due to
the due to the monster night on d6 so
rajabu doesn't like 97 he captures
immediately with Knight character Sun b6
e capture Sun b6 and now we have f6
taking away the e5 square from whites
night it's very important f6 and now
comes Knight to h4 you've taken away one
square for the knight but by playing f6
you also allowed the g6 Square to be
occupied by whites night so night stage
4 we have King to f7 and now just f4 and
now if you look at this this night isn't
really going anywhere you can go here
you can go here you can't go here you
you can go here but you're not really
going anywhere from there so by the
looks of it you know Roger was Dark
Knight isn't about to rise anytime soon
so King to EA t' and now we have f5 of
course nakamura wants to open up the
position he wants to if this pawn
captures then rook to e1 will be very
strong just you know a lot of options
here and here there are a couple of
moves you could play so first I'll just
let you to pause the video and you know
feel free to decide how you would
continue this game from blacks
perspective I'll give you a couple of
seconds as it's very you know it's a
really a critical position for those of
you who were able to defend here you are
just an excellent defender and for the
Jew who just won't enjoy the show best
idea here is Queen to c5 just waiting to
see what white will do and
now White has to decide what to do here
best best idea is to go Knight to g6
just trading there but the thing is and
the point is if you capture here which
is the main idea Knight captures and now
you don't really have a good follow up
now you can either go Knight to g6 and
continue the attack or if rook to e1
then you no longer control the d6
squared and rook captures and d6 will be
very strong the knight is defended
everything works out for for black so
after this f5 move Queen to c5 was the
best idea but her job of played not pawn
captures not going to c5 but rather he
advanced the pawn and it seems like the
best course of action for black as you
don't want the e-file opened but it is
also the move that loses the game so
here we have some nice photos of a
couple of younger members of the
audience here you can see this little
gentleman here cannot believe what a
javo just did he pushed e5 and also we
have this little gentleman here he had
to drop his shades to check if if Jabba
really did play e5 as it is such a such
a wonderful losing move but again feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find how to take advantage of this e5
blunder from from a team of rajab oh
I'll give you a couple of seconds as it
is a very nice positional idea for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of nice positional ideas and for
those who just want to enjoy a show as
usual the best move is to centralize the
Queen if you can even if you don't know
why you're doing it you should always
centralize your Queen 25 and now there
are so many threats black will simply
not be able to take care of all of them
just to give you an example if black
just plays something let's say like a 5
then the idea is nice to g6 and now
after Knight captures you will play H
captures and I'll notice that the pawns
here are really controlling all the
squares in front of the black King
there's already the threat of just Queen
to g8 checkmate so to prevent this you
would have to go King to f8 but then you
get rook to c2 threatening rook to c8
and now after the Queen defends this now
you go rook the c6 just defending the d6
pawn for the moment next you're gonna
play Queen to c5 and then you will want
to win with rook the c8
if Queen to be
seven getting the Queen added way now
queen c5 and after King to e8 which is
the only defense basically against rook
here you will be able to block here but
now just Rock the b6 and the black Queen
doesn't really have all that many moves
if Queen to a7 then you play Queen
captures on b5 and black is not without
a move you can't really play anything
the rook is pinned if you move the King
you're going to lose the rook if you
just move the King here then you're
getting checkmated after rook to b8 if
you move the Queen upwards then again
you're just gonna lose the Queen and
you're getting checkmate it very quickly
so there is nothing you can do here with
the black pieces so this is the idea and
what what problems lie in in how to
defend with the black pieces here so
here a job of tried a different idea he
played Queen to e3 his idea is okay
white can go whatever he wants to go
maybe I will be able to grab some
perpetual checking ideas after after
let's say Queen Queen to f4 check but
Nakamura has it all figured out he goes
Knight to g6 all the same so for the
moment you can't go to f4 that's just
taken but a job of captures with H
captures and now comes Queen to f4 check
so let's see what's Nakamura had in mind
we have King to h3
now comes Queen to f1 check King to h4
and now you don't really have a good
follow up if you play rook captures here
white will just ignore you but even if
even if you try this Queen to h1 doesn't
really do anything
I've Queen to h1 you can just defend
King g3 and and out there there are no
good follow ups if here you can just
block and you will eventually run out of
checks and white will just win the game
on the other hand you don't even have to
do it if if ro captures you can just go
Queen f7 check King gate and now rook
captures which makes a lot more sense
but even if Nakamura was to play a
dangerous game and allow some checks it
wouldn't really work so here Rajjo
played a queen to be one check instead
we have King to h5 and it was in this
position that Tim or a job of resign the
game and move 41 as there is nothing
more he can do any move you play let's
say you go hey five or something I just
going to g8 is checkmate there's nowhere
to go the points really do
job of preventing from getting from
escaping you can't escape with the king
if you move the King then sorry if you
move the King any sorry any check will
work Queen to g8 or Queen to a8 again
the pawn really doing a nice job here
and well any any other moves are really
not working here you could actually try
rock out for some v6 and of course if
Queen captures then white is in trouble
Queen to h2 will lead the checkmate as
after Queen captures the black king has
nowhere to go but I like in the other
line after rope captures white will just
ignore you you can go Queen to f7 check
and after King moves you will very
quickly deliver checkmate with King to
c8 Queen d7 check King here
rugby six check and then Queen B 7 will
be checkmate so after King to h5 our job
of of course did not attempt such a such
a silly lion against Nakamura as you
know he respects him and and just too
much but you know if you're if you're
playing like a game that's not very
important or a bullet or blitz game then
you should try anything to you know not
not lose the game but yeah now that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
excellent game by Cora Nakamura and you
know as they say without brilliant
without error there can be no brilliancy
so here we had the error which is the e5
just seems like a very nice idea and but
you know it simply doesn't work Queen d5
just a beautiful centralizing move that
allows White's to win in in anyway yeah
well pretty much that he wants and here
we also have a nice nice photo of
Nakamura and her job of after the game
giving interviews you know analyzing
their game saying what was what and I
didn't catch the live coverage but if
you have and I'm sure it's available
somewhere online if you're interested
you can also check that out if some of
you have a link to that feel free to
also post that in the description in the
comments below I will pin it to give it
a heart so everyone can see yeah I'm
also very interested in your opinion if
you've seen the the Game of Thrones
finale what's your what your you know
take on the show and on the entire
eighth season but you know do do should
do start with spoiler in the comments so
you don't ruin it for everyone else
but yeah yeah that's the game I hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Norman
Hardin Tara Scarpia Clifford Dibble
young if Sheena and Tim or Ishmael look
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Fida
Grand Prix 2019 and you know of course
the capablanca saga and checking up on
your suggestions I think you all have an
excellent rest of your day and I will
see you soon